toujours avec Michael elmidoro et Paul
Hermitage ancien directeur du Golf
National de 50 ans Nîmes on disait qu'il
vient d'être nommé au sport manager
sport très précisément sport manager
même au golf du golf au comité
d'organisation des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 voilà j'ai remis tout toutes
les données dans le bon sens des
épreuves bien sûr de golf vont se
dérouler sur le territoire des Yvelines
au Golf National de 50 ans en Inuits
nous disait tout à l'heure pour les
remitage que vous n'avez pas hésité très
longtemps avant de donner votre aval
votre accord pour pour cette mission
comment ça s'est fait justement vous
avez commencé à le dire comment c'est
fait cette nomination et comment la
prise de contact s'est-elle faite la
prise de contact est venue de part
l'européenne tour qu'on connaît bien
parce qu'ils organisent l'Open de France
et puis et puis la Ryder Cup qui
détenteur de droits de Ryder Cup parce
qu'ils font partie eux d'un consortium
qui a été créé pour les jeux qui est
dirigé par le international de la
Fédération internationale de golf comme
les fédérations fonctionne tous les
sports de des JO et qui a réuni tous les
experts du golf mondiaux donc le DP
World Tour européen tour la PGA Tour qui
est américain Ladies Tour européen et
américains et la Fédération Française de
Golf donc sans font partie d'un
consortium qui vont livrer le côté
sportif du Golfe et il cherchait
effectivement quelqu'un maintenant a été
je pense dire et au sort non je pense
les sorties de du chapeau et voilà
comment est venu le contact de par
2018 il y a une expérience à la tête du
Golf National mais surtout à la tête du
Golf National pendant un événement
majeur comme la Ryder Cup en 2018
sont effectivement
la raison pour laquelle j'étais choisi
il y avait pas vraiment l'avènement
parce que la Ryder Cup était organisé
par une organisation internationale mais
mais déjà de préparer le golf telle
épreuve pour accueillir le monde entier
à ce niveau là bon c'est c'est clair que
ça c'est plutôt bien passé et de mettre
en place les équipes et puis
l'expérience golfeur etc tout ce que
vous connaissez déjà là-bas alors sport
Manager au sein du comité d'organisation
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques en
charge du golf concrètement c'est quoi
ça va être quoi votre mission alors en
fait il y a ce qu'on appelle aussi je
vais parler beaucoup anglais mais il y a
un CDE un camp petit jeune entité qui
livre le sport qui est externalisé à
Paris 2024 c'est uniquement c'est
seulement dans le golf qu'on voit ça
tous les autres CDE sont internalisés à
parler des mécanes donc en fait moi je
suis salarié d'une fédération
internationale et qui a été missionné
par les 2024 pour le golf donc mon rôle
consiste à créer l'équipe de ce CDE
une équipe de professionnels pour
pouvoir
délivrer tout ce que a besoin les
athlètes pour aller vers la livraison
des médailles on va dire en passant par
une partie de la préparation du parcours
avec les agronomistes et puis Lucas
Pierrick qui est le l'intendant au golf
national en partant par le la
préparation du site pour
les athlètes au niveau de de du jeu
voilà donc toute la partie sportive tout
ce que ça peut comprendre
sachant que il y a la partie
événementielle dans tout ce qui est
hospitalité tente transport par les les
services de Paris 4 et on est obligé de
travailler ensemble pour le transport
des athlètes pour le médical pour le
dopping pour etc etc donc il y a
énormément de différentes domaines à
penser et c'est une organisation qui est
complètement différente de la Ryder club
donc j'apprends aussi tous les jours et
c'est ça qui m'a aussi fait venir dans
ce rôle c'est d'apprendre également
nickel et comment ça va se dérouler avec
Philippe pilateau qui l'actuel directeur
du Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines très bien très
bien parce que on est je dirais pas je
dirais pas jusqu'à dire frère mais mais
presque
Philips c'est quelqu'un qui je retrouve
au golf en 2013 quand je suis arrivé qui
avait une toute autre mission
il a une telle empathie telle sympathie
c'est quelqu'un d'extraordinairement
humain et urbain j'ai dit toi tu viens
avec moi et tu vas livrer tout cet amour
vers les clients donc il est vite fait
devenu un peu mon assistant au adjoint
sur le côté service client et c'était
tout naturel quand je suis parti que qui
prennent la place dont il mérité tant
voilà donc un tel respect on va
travailler très bien ensemble alors on
va passer à l'organisation est-ce que
tout est prêt à environ un peu moins de
500 jours de ces Jeux Olympiques alors
tout est prêt alors bien sûr ouais on va
dire que pour tout ce ce qui concerne le
parcours on connaît les talents qu'il y
existent au golf national au niveau de
l'entretien je dirais quotidien
du parcours de golf donc je pense qu'on
a aucun souci à voir par rapport à la
qualité du parcours même si quelques
standards et des normes vont changer
pour les équipes en place parce qu'on
est plus sur un modèle américain que sur
de livraison de l'événement que sur un
modèle européen
l'agronomiste conseil est un Américain
et bien la semaine prochaine d'ailleurs
pendant deux jours ce qui nous change un
petit peu on était tellement habitué à
setup d'un parcours de de préparer le
parcours pour les Européens et là on le
prépare pour un plateau mondial donc ça
ça peut changer après sur le reste de
l'organisation moi je suis très confiant
je vais dire oui parce que on a un plan
évidemment heureusement d'ailleurs à 500
jours mais des visites comme aujourd'hui
là je sors du Golf National aujourd'hui
était extrêmement productif avec toutes
les équipes de de structures
d'infrastructures de de du management de
l'événement les entrées publiques
comment on va faire les flux sur le site
parce que on vise quand même 25 à 30 000
personnes sur le site chaque jour il
faut pas oublier non plus que ce qui
nous change aussi c'est que la rider
c'était trois jours plus de jours
d'entraînement et là on est sur huit
jours de compétition ça change
complètement le format rider avec le
format Jeux Olympiques 472 jours un très
exactement avant les cours j'ai vérifié
et appuyer ça change c'est quand même un
format différent absolument là on a
c'est comme si on avait deux Open de
France
une semaine après l'autre une pour les
filles qui est qui est une opportunité
aussi pour nous tous parce que
bah on a les viandes Championship qui
est à Évian qui est un majeur mais le
National n'a pas vraiment accueilli non
plus un grand tournoi pour les pour les
filles jusqu'à maintenant et donc ça
c'est une opportunité mais deux semaines
de suite comme ça ça met une charge
importante sur le sur le parcours et sur
sur les équipes on attend pour une
dernière question Michael dernière
question un peu piège pour vous
Apollinaire est-ce que vous allez
soutenir l'équipe de France ou la
Grande-Bretagne pour les Jeux Olympiques
de 2024 alors c'est pas une question
piège je sais pas si vous le savez mais
juste avant de quitter le Golf National
j'ai obtenu la naturalisation française
donc je suis français
mais par contre
le cas le 15 mars juste avant le
confinement j'ai reçu mon comment dire
ma lettre du Premier ministre en disant
voilà vous avez obtenu votre votre
nationalité donc je suis aussi français
que vous avec une acte de naissance mais
le cœur sportif malheureusement il est
toujours autre manche on précise alors
que la team Grande-Bretagne sera
accueillie dans les Yvelines du côté de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye sur les Jeux
Olympiques qui vont s'entraîner du coup
au Camp des Loges mais je crois aussi
qui vont venir faire quelques
déplacements peut-être sur le Golf
National où ils vont rester à
Saint-Germain les peut-être pour les
entraînements
ça vous savez pas encore c'est pas
encore connu et et je reste au niveau
des informations éclaircir en tout cas
merci Paul invitation d'être venu en
plateau on rappelle juste que les
épreuves de golf sur c'est Jeux
Olympiques se dérouleront du premier au
4 août pour la compétition masculine et
du 7 au 10 août pour le tournoi féminin